i had a question about doing the
ayahuasca i've done a dmt and is there
anything close to it i just wanted to
know the similarities with it because
it's kind of the same thing
um
thank you for the question there i
appreciate it
and um
you know my experience dmt was very much
like somebody
kicked you like beat you in the head
with a uh dave and busters
that's what it's like
it was like two angry gay dudes attacked
you at a
at a dave and busters
because you're seeing all these crazy
shapes there's a lot of rainbows there's
some bears there's some stuff that look
like a orifice or whatever
um it has a very kind of a
booty carnival
type of
dirty uh
magnificent
um colorful
it's like somebody
it's like
god hit you with a mirror but he hit you
hard and he hit you fast
and the cops showed up
and all that you know and the cops are
from heaven and hell and it all happened
in a matter of minutes
that to me was dmt
a lot of that
and you end up [ __ ] sitting there
talking to like an oyster or something
just some [ __ ] that you're like i don't
know what this is you know they got a
koala over there and he's puffing
winston's bro he's doing his best
you know when he's out of work probably
you know sure chipotle is trying to hire
him
to work next to that vamp kid who can't
handle the freaking
yo you ask him one question he's like oh
you don't know
i don't know i need to sleep
um
that was dmt for me man dmt was like uh
somebody took a pinball machine
and buried you in it
they opened the glass up and put you in
there and the game is still going on
there's still somebody hitting the
paddles the balls are scooting around
and it's multi-ball somebody accessed a
multi-ball
so they're all and then you're just
laying and they put the glass back on
and you're laying in there
face down
that to me is dmt that's what dmt was
like
it's a couple minutes you come out of it
you're in maui
the guy who's doing it with you you met
at a smoothie stand you know he's a good
guy
he gave you some magnesium you know it's
uh it is what it is
ayahuasca is
ayahuasca is like a key i think
it's like an invitation
you take it
you sit there
you're meditating
there's no party about it there's
nothing like uh
we're gonna do this in a back room at a
party that's not
now you can still do it in a back room
but
it's more of a experience
and it's a longer experience
and it's really
you start to learn about yourself
you learn some truths about yourself
you know i was sitting there and i mean
people are like did you go to peru did
you go to you know
myanmar or whatever
like dude i did that [ __ ] right off the
101 bruh
i did that i was i i was probably
180 yards from my pot pies chicken
you know and a dsw shoes dude i could
see there were moments in some of my
visions and stuff that somebody would
you know
you know walk by with a damn pair of
birkenstocks on so
i
was you know i wasn't out in the abyss
but the environment i was in was really
nice
uh in the sense that it was it had a
great shaman and great people doing it
and i'm sitting in there and you take
the medics you take the medicines and
it's almost like your heart starts to
dream
or think
and it's really wild because you start
to get thoughts that come out of your
it's almost like they come out of the
time
that's trapped
inside of you
it's like your heart gets a brain
um
you know i remember
sitting there and uh
and you just start to go it's like
it's like a best friend shows up
and starts to share stuff with you that
you're willing to hear
because you um
usually because you've been suffering
with something
you know
oh
and so it starts to kind of unearth some
of that
and you go through the different
experiences and you're like man that was
a lot you know i learned a lot of stuff
about myself
it's like therapy but you don't have to
do a lot of the heavy lifting
i mean it's like the goddess you know
the
like god brings the wood right up to you
you know the fire will you don't have to
go out and
chop you just open the door and it's all
firewood you can't even see the world
it's just
all your firewood is right there
and the gu and god has chopped it for
you
and so you could this is so at that
point it's really an invitation it's
like how much do you want to know
that's what it feels like to me
how much do you want to know
my last experience man i went and
you know i'd really been struggling with
a lot of stuff about my mother uh and my
relationship with my mother
and my inability to have a connection
with my mother a deep connection
you know i'd always wanted it
and um
and so i'm sitting there under the
ayahuasca and
and i've always struggled in
relationships commitment
i've really always struggled
and
while i'm under this ayahuasca while i'm
in the experience of the medication
i realize that the reason i have trouble
getting into a relationship or being
committed
uh well there's two reasons one
is that part of me is still waiting for
this relationship with my mother to
really
um
come through
there's part of me that's still like
this young kid that's still just
standing there waiting
for his mother
to really
connect with him
and so it's really hard for me
to make another commitment to another
woman it's really hard for me
uh
and i didn't know it was because there's
a part of me that's still just literally
standing there waiting
and that sounds kind of crazy but
when you're under the medication it
makes a lot of sense
because it really activates the inner
child in you
and you really get to see what the
very young you the formative you what he
what he or she went through
um
and you see why they went through it and
how it affected them and then how that
affects you now
it's almost like as an adult you're a
plant
but on ayahuasca you get to go back to
the seed
and you get to look in the seed
and the seed gets to communicate the
seed communicates with you
the you the you the early you the
formative you
um
but so it's a lot different in that
sense you really get to sit there and
and
and be with a lot of the things that
have made you uncomfortable but now
you're able to see okay this is why i
behave this way as an adult
because this happened when i was young
and you always can kind of
in therapy sometimes you'll talk about
those things but to really have a real
connection between them and to really
feel that connection is pretty powerful
uh
and also it's a it's a
it's an invitation in a way because
ayahuasca is an invitation
because it's really how much of that
stuff do you want to learn and go into
because it feels like there's a lot of
it
my second experience i sat there for
probably
oh i can't even tell you
i mean just tons of time you just cry i
mean i was just grieving just crying
i was grieving like um you know when i
was 12 or 10 my brother
he got to go live with my grandparents
and
that sounds like a small thing but
that broke my heart
it broke my heart as a kid
that my mother let him go
it bro i mean it really
because he was the closest thing that i
felt to uh to love you know or to a real
friend or something
and
and here was my mother and she let him
go
just do what he wanted like he was an
adult it just was
and that [ __ ] broke my heart man so
but there's a lot of things inside of
you that you've been resilient through
and but you're able to go and look at
those things and let
kind of let the air out of some of those
balloons you know
it's like your soul gets to fart kinda
you know you're able to go and unpack a
lot of these things that really could
have really and and probably had a big
effect on your life and how you behave
now
um
so anyway it's tough because it's hard
for me to go into some of that
you know a lot of it's real painful i
went and spoke with my mom
after the holidays about uh
you know about some about
a lot of the feelings i was having
and i you know and about how much i felt
neglected really
and
and it was hard man i'm glad i was able
to give myself a voice but it was it was
it was tough
because it was also a long time ago
you know and um
[Music]
and so you don't want to damage the
person you're talking to or upset you
know you don't but you do want to share
what's going on
uh and what you're feeling and learning
um
so that's ayahuasca man if you want
ayahuasca you're gonna go down a real
or you could go down
you know a real
rabbit hole
a real invitation to say okay how much
because you can keep going and doing it
and that's where i'm at now i don't know
if i want to go back sometimes
right now
uh
i mean the the the
the last time i went man it was it was
cathartic
but it was damn painful man
it was painful it was cathartic in the
way you sit there and you know
you
[Music]
you cry for the things that you get
those tears all the [ __ ] that's in you
get it out
you get it out you cook it right up out
of your system
um
but it's a lot of work i mean it is it's
the hardest thing i've ever had to do
it's like i i
you know i would imagine it's like boot
camp or something but for your
for your heart and for your
soul and stuff
so
um
i don't know if that does a good job of
explaining it but that's some of the
differences i noticed between them one
of them is a real
one of them is like going to a carnival
and the other one is like
going to
it's like going into an ocean
so that's my thoughts on the difference
between i think dmt and ayahuasca is
ayahuasca can really
it can re i mean dmt shows you that
you know dmt is kind of like a firework
kind of but ayahuasca is a damn [ __ ]
jesus
it's a fire
it's a fire man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one